part of why it is so hard to understand
ourselves is that people are constantly
doing things to us that defy the common
sense view of how human beings might
plausibly behave around people they
claim to care about
we expect that those who might carry the
title of mum or dad or husband or wife
would unless they had very clear reasons
to do otherwise show us kindness
and yet the brutal reality which we must
take on board for our own sanity
is that humans are frequently beset by
feelings that are so intolerable
and difficult they develop urges to pass
them on to others in a version of
emotional past the parcel
put another way humans can end up being
cruel
not for money or territory
but in the hope of alleviating their own
sufferings by making someone near them
suffer in their stead
cruelty is at heart an attempt to make
ourselves feel better by doing to
someone else a version of what was done
to us
amidst the seeming normality of family
life
people will hence inject someone else a
spouse a child
with a poison
an ill will a contempt a hostility
which they then deny ever having put
into their bloodstream and which the
victim themselves can't clearly detect
so invested are they in thinking well of
those around them
a mother might for example inject her
daughter with a poison that says
don't ever succeed in your life
it would make me feel too bad about
myself
or a father will inject his son with a
poison whose meaning is
i want you to fail in your career to
alleviate my sense of disappointment
or a spouse will inject their partner
with a poison that carries the meaning
i will constantly but very subtly
disrespect your intelligence and your
sexuality to lessen the feelings of rage
and powerlessness i experienced when i
was little
such injections wouldn't work if they
were noticed so enormous energy goes
into the cover-up
it's debatable how much the injector
even understands what they are up to
they are more driven to act than cleanly
aware of how or why they are doing so
a big part of self-knowledge means
realizing that those we love and have
trusted may have put some hugely
damaging ideas inside us
that need to be identified and corrected
to help us to attain the freedom and
light-heartedness we crave and deserve
how to overcome your childhood is a book
that teaches us how character is
developed the concept of emotional
inheritance the formation of our
concepts of being good or bad and the
impact of parental styles of love on the
way we choose adult partners